how many people are infected with the
corona virus what will it mean for our
hospitals and how many of us will die
those are the questions that are at the
front of everyone's mind to get the best
possible sense of things
I turn to Reason science correspondent
Ronald Bailey to discuss the constantly
changing often contradictory information
coming from official channels we are
going through this almost daily change
up of what you know how many people of
us are infected and how many people who
are infected are gonna die what is the
latest reading that you have on this
well in the United States okay we're
we're talking basically on a Friday
afternoon it's around just shy of 90,000
Americans are diagnosed with having been
infected with the the corona virus that
causes carbon 19 the number of deaths is
around 1500 at this point so that's
where we're standing at currently
continues to accelerate it's going
faster and the question is how much
faster is it going to go and how I will
get before it turns around right so can
you answer any of those questions what
are what are the best guesses because
you know we hear constantly changing
idea you know that the CDC awhile ago
had a worst case scenario that had
something like 1.7 million Americans
dying in the worst case scenario we
heard from Imperial College in London
that ain't no it could be a couple of
million people etc what it break down
the infection rate and the case fatality
rate for us in ways that you know give
us some clarity well the truth is we
don't know what the infection rate is
but the only way we could know that is
to know the number of people who are
infected and all we know are the number
of people who are diagnosed so we can
have the case fatality rate which is the
diagnosed cases versus and there are
people who are dead who are dead and
that's 1.5 percent which is terrible but
again we don't really know if that is
the way the whole epidemic epidemic is
going to play out because we don't know
how many people out there undetected
cases already who are either mild a sub
or whatever and we really need to know
that to figure out just how bad leave
the this epidemic is likely to evolve
every time at 1.5 by the way again we
can compare these rates between
countries right now that same case
fatality rate using again diagnosed
people and dead people and in Italy is
nearly 10% that is 10% of the people who
have been diagnosed have died with the
disease that's horrific but again even
in Italy we have no idea how many people
have actually been affected so we don't
know if that rates going to remain
anywhere close to that in fact my
suspicion is well it all remains as as
close to that and that's partly because
I mean obviously early on especially in
places where testing was limited the
worst cases are the only people who are
being tested and so they're more likely
to die that's not it we talked a couple
of weeks ago I guess now about
coronavirus and yeah you know just to
kind of update on some of those
conversations what you know the case
fatality rate or overall once we know
everybody who is infected and how many
people died
we were talking around 1 percent of
people who are infected die it does that
seem likely to hold up or does that seem
high or low or there's just no way of
telling it's really hard to tell I've
been combing through the statistics all
across the world trying to figure that
one out myself and again you have
estimates for example by a researcher
who my for whom I have great respect
johnny unitas at stanford university who
is a genius statistician who has
suggested we have we don't have enough
data to even tells it's going to be
below the average for seasonal that
seasonal flu death rate and which would
be amazing if true and be it would be
absolutely wonderful when get out of
this lockdown but he also admits it
could be considerably higher than that
it could be up to one and a half to two
percent of the population which then
would go back to those catastrophic
rates that had been projected earlier by
the models he's saying that we have a
tremendous rain
that we simply don't have enough data to
decide on I think his suspicion is that
it's going to be at the lower into that
range and so far we don't know again it
isn't the more people we test the lower
the range seems to go across the planet
but again we haven't tested nearly
enough people to figure out what the
infection or the if you will the
infection fatality radius as opposed to
the case fatality rate right and in the
end I mean it's the infection fatality
rate there right I think most people are
concerned with right that's that's
correct what you know are the early
discussions of coronavirus as mostly
killing people who are 70 or older does
that seem to be holding up I mean I've
been reading stories about younger
people dying from the from the disease
and whatnot you know what's the latest
information you've seen on that
basically about 60% of the cases of
people who have died in even the United
States are 70 and older so yes that
continues to hold up but of course
that's also true for things like
seasonal flu the majority of people who
die of seasonal flu in the United States
also are people in that age group you
have talked to and written about
basically there are about 2.4 million
deaths a year in America right that's
about right yeah and so what you know
and I mean this sounds grim but on
another level we are you know we are in
a complete lockdown as a country I mean
we'd have really ground almost all
activity to a halt there you know that's
considered non-essential the economy is
tanking etc what well at what level do
we start to say okay this amount of
death is a reason to shut everything
down as opposed to this is something we
can live with what what goes into those
kinds of Public Health decisions well
that's the thing
you you have to have the information on
the likelihood of the of the numbers of
people who are going to die and again if
it's a hundred thousand I suspect it
would be tragedy would be terrible but I
think most people would go to know we
don't shut down the economy for that it
would be sort of like an especially bad
flu season
and so we wouldn't shut down the economy
for that but then as you escalate it up
if it's a half a million
well maybe we do again these are these
are this is what we have politicians a
policymakers are supposed to try to make
these trade-offs for us in some sense
rather if we're going to to apply to
apply draconian public health measures
which we're certainly doing right we
certainly are doing how how I guess a
couple things how confident are you that
the the lockdown model which is now in
place basically everywhere is that going
to contain things you know first off
like do we know with any certainty or
what are the what are the kind of
milestones that we look to to say okay
this is working well it did apparently
work and to the degree that we think
that's fine is being honest about their
statistics it does apparently seem to
have worked there but it was quite
returning as you know we the places
we're just in the West where we've just
now done it it will take another week or
so for us to know whether or not that's
going to flatten the curve and so that
means the number of is that the number
of deaths is that the number of
infections I mean it would be both there
is all of this is hard to know because
the testing is is kind of like a moving
target right we're testing many more
people now so the data we're getting is
not directly comparable to even a week
ago right and it's not only testing is
that people who you know the the
infection period is five to 14 days so
people may not know yet if they're going
to get the disease and that would have
to unfold over this period of time so
that we have a better idea of how many
people actually got infected prior to
the lockdown
what are the you know what are the
lessons that we can learn already from
the way that the various government
whether it was local state or federal
health agencies responded to the early
cases of this what what do we know went
wrong and what are we doing to correct
that course well from from my particular
point of view and I've been I'm somewhat
obsessive about this is the main problem
was that there was a complacency to it
there was not enough testing done the
states were actually fall
the directions of the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention and and
basically only testing people who had
traveled or to China or back from China
and and and people who had been
associated with them and this by doing
that they missed the fact that the
disease had already begun spreading
throughout the country and by missing
that if we we missed the opportunity for
basically finding out who was infected
getting their contacts and telling
everyone in that group to stay home we
might have been able to contain the the
epidemic a lot more than we have been
able to do so that's the main failure I
don't think that we can blame the state
governments for that they were following
but they thought were federal guidelines
so I think it was a massive failure on
the part of our federal public health
officials you know you you've written
about this the FDA now which is in
charge of drug testing and whatnot
has put a stop a moratorium on at home
testing what does that what does that
mean and why is that a bad thing well at
home testing right now would be
something to be rolled out very fast in
fact there were four companies that were
planning to do that earlier this week
and they thought that they had reason to
do that under the FDA's emergency use
regulations but then the FDA said but no
you can't do that they might be
fraudulent but the four companies that
were doing this under no circumstances
were fraudulent companies they have
already our diagnostic companies they
know how to do this the samples they're
going to get from their customers we're
gonna we're going to go to fda-approved
labs for tests for you know for testing
and it was it seemed like a perfectly
reasonable thing to do and this will be
one way to roll out and get a lot more
data from the public about how how broad
this this epidemic is at this point all
of these data would have been reported
to public health authorities and we
would have a much better idea if they
had allowed that to go forward what what
goes into you know I can't ask you to
like read the minds of bureaucrats or
whatever but what why in this moment
what they still be you know kind of
sticking to ways that I've already been
kind of superseded by event
it's an extremely good question the
problem is that no bureaucrat ever wants
to be so be told that they had approved
something that turns out to harm
somebody and one of the concerns and
they should be concerned about this
there are a lot of quacks out there who
are trying to offer cures for
coronavirus this that and the other
thing and that that doesn't need to be
monitored and has to be stopped
and and that's their role to do that but
these tests clearly do not fall in that
category of fraudulent products that
would be available to the public and if
this should have been obvious they know
these companies what what countries so
far or subunits within the United States
you think have done the best job of you
know kind of dealing with containing you
know the corona virus I mean we hear
from about South Korea Taiwan Singapore
you know doing a good job of doing mass
testing and locking people down and
quarantine people who are infected
countries like the Netherlands and
Sweden seem to be allowing a kind of
herd mentality you know way of dealing
with this can you talk about what seems
to be working or are there places in the
United States that are doing a
particularly good job
well let's divide that up let's look at
what's going on briefly in the
Netherlands and Sweden they they haven't
locked down their entire countries
though their entire countries but they
have begun to close down cafes bars that
kind of thing and to and to prevent
certain kind of gatherings anymore the
idea there's a model inside the
Netherlands where the epidemiologists
there thought that the the casualties if
you were the deaths wouldn't be that
great and so the government is actually
following that model and hoping that
that their statisticians are better than
our statisticians and we will see the
thing is is that in the end the last
week or so the Netherlands rates for
infections and and and for deaths is
accelerating so they may have made the
wrong bet again we won't know for
another week or so
Sweden's rates are also accelerating as
far as I can tell at this point as well
so they may be moving in the direction
of a lockdown or not again let a
thousand flowers bloom and we'll have
better data it may be tragic for the
Netherlands or Sweden or it may turn out
we've not care economy into a dart a
black hole for no good reason
we'll find out can you talk about the
Imperial College numbers because this
you know and again you know this is like
you know at after 9/11 we all became in
a structural engineer or some you know
within 48 hours after 9/11 we all became
financial sector analysts you know and
now we're everybody's being asked to be
a kind of armchair epidemiologist we
heard from Imperial College of London
you know a study came out that was so
influential and so terrifying that
England reversed course and went to lock
down rather than new herd immunity then
a couple days ago you know apparently
the the main one of the main people
behind that study said look we're gonna
be okay then he seems so a reverse
course what what is going on there and
what is the you know ultimately what's
the import for those of us you know
trying to figure out what what's going
on
well what the Imperial College model did
was basically as said assume the
government's and people make no changes
whatsoever in the face of the epidemic
this is how many people will die and
this is how many ICU beds we'll need and
the results were terrifying but they
made the untenable assumption that
nobody was ever going to do anything
about the thing other than get the
disease and die
well alright that's a nice baseline to
have but is a good way to make policy
well then the next problem is is that
the guy who's the head of it a guy named
Neil Ferguson testified in front of a
parliamentary committee well thank
goodness is only going to be 20,000
people dying instead of 500,000 people
dying in Britain now and the reason was
that because the lockdown is working so
what he basically did as far as I can
tell is go back to his model and said
assume that the lockdown works perfectly
how well will we do so again it's
another assumption the lockdown is now
working perfectly and therefore we will
get rid of all those extra X excess
infections and deaths that were
before both of them again our
speculation we don't know so at what
point does you know and there seems to
be a brewing kind of tension between
epidemiologists or we're focusing on
data as it becomes available and as it
becomes better more numerous and hence
more representative and modeling at what
point do you put the numbers we have
into a model and kind of figure out
what's you know what's the likelihood
that this is actually representing
reality as opposed to you know edge so
far it seems like everybody is being
pulled by a model that is abstract and
generally at the horrifying end of
things so how do we go forward from here
in terms of modeling well first of all
part of the reason that people are
focusing on the horrifying is that they
would say out of an abundance of caution
yeah the other truths that a matter is
and you know this as well as I do that
those people who are reporting on this
those members of the fellow member are
fellow journalists will tend to focus on
the high-end number because that's the
one that catches people's attention but
the thing is the models are never going
to tell us what the results are what we
really need to do is to roll out a
massive amount of testing eventually
everybody but that that's another public
policy thing but what we really need to
do now is to do a a fairly wide scale
random testing of the American
population to find out just how many
people are infected if we have that
bottom line then we can immediately we
don't need the model we can go and count
the number of deaths and then figure out
how terrifying it is or not terrifying
it is and asami so the main thing the
government should do from my point of
view is go out and start doing testing
as much as possible to get those data so
we'll know what we're faces is it likely
that there aren't going to be massive
variation regionally throughout the
country and so that what is working or
what what is necessary in New York City
or the New York metro area is very
different from Indianapolis from Dallas
from Phoenix there there will be
regional variations but for example you
could do
massive testing in New York City and
have a good idea a very good idea of how
bad is going to be in New York which
would then also be you could extrapolate
that presumably I presume that New
Yorkers do not have a weaker immune
systems and the rest of Americans so you
would be able to extrapolate that again
to the infected fatality rate and for
any any area so you could assume if
Indianapolis eventually had his met you
know the same percentage of the
population having the disease as New
York does then you would end up with
this many dead it wouldn't be that hard
to do what is the you know going forward
so you know in your if if things went
according to your lights we would have
massive testing and you know and either
a lockdown or a kind of you know more
freedom of movement based on you know
what's happening with things like with
the infection rate and the death rate
what about vaccines or how do we clear
this in a way that we're not worrying
about it every year or is that just I
mean is the corona virus or something
like it gonna be
an add-on to the annual what is it like
ten thousand to sixty thousand annual
flu deaths in a given year is this just
we're just going to be coming back to
this every year that's an extremely good
question and the I think the answer is
probably it'll be an add-on it's
probably you can't you can't put it back
in the box
the so on top of our flu vaccine every
year we may get a corona virus vaccine
though this the good news is this one
doesn't seem to be mutating at all the
same way that flu does so we probably
may not need an annual version of it and
which feels like it can actually be once
it once we're immune to it it basically
it it's not being a threat it stops
being a big threat right do we you know
why is it attacking older people because
one of the things that is odd is the flu
is kind of you know an equal opportunity
killer right no no okay so explain that
now the flu actually kills older folks
probably about the same percentage rate
as the corona virus does the the
majority of flu test in the United
States every year are people over age 65
okay so and as far as it because
unfortunately as we get older our immune
systems become weaker over time they're
less responsive do you you know the one
criticism that comes up now is that
there is essentially no financial
incentive for a pharmaceutical company
to develop vaccines for things like this
is that is that a apt criticism of the
system and if so what are the ways to
incentivize quick-moving you know
pharmaceutical interventions or other
types of medical interventions into
something like this right well one of
the things that you know right now
they're trying it right now right now a
lot of researchers are using a lot of
the antivirals for example that were
developed during the Ebola crisis that
occurred and those one simple excuse me
what's a bowl that was defeated they
these antivirals were put back on the
shelf and nobody tested them anymore and
what should have happened probably is to
continue trying it on various possible
theoretical if you will infections such
as corona virus we know the corona virus
that could transfer over up to people
because we had the SARS virus do that in
the early part of the century
and later on the MERS virus which was
out of the Middle East so we know the
corona virus is always out there ready
to come over for us and now finally what
has gotten there so there were actually
companies that's mark you know could
have been testing their antivirals
against these viruses all along had they
been incentivized to do that one one
potty one of the one of the ways we
could you could do it as a prize let's
say basically have companies identify
threats and develop if you will vaccines
and/or antivirals we ended by
sooo to address them that's a that's
also a problem by the way with
antibiotics nowadays is is that they're
very little incentive for companies to
develop those four if you will bacterial
infections as well so what we need to do
is to figure out how to identify
promising products and then incentivize
companies to go forward with them a
prize of a hundred million dollars each
might be interesting yeah and that would
I mean that would be cheaper ultimately
than we're looking at trillions of
dollars in either direct payments or in
fed money and things like what you know
what are the essential particularly from
a libertarian perspective where you know
what we're trying to do is to maintain
limited government rule of law you know
as much autonomy for individuals to make
decisions about their lives there's
always you know some level of tension
between public health and you know what
kind of libertarian understanding of
things but you know they're not you know
they're not mutually exclusive by any
stretch what are the essential lessons
from from a public health perspective do
we need to learn and kind of insist on
going forward that does as much as
possible to you know prevent this type
of thing from reoccurring or happening
on a regular basis and maintain a kind
of individual freedom to the greatest
degree possible the two things I would
like to say about that one is that when
you we're having pandemics or epidemics
that kind of thing they're occurring and
essentially an open-access Commons and
the problem with the Commons is is that
we you know we libertarians typically
like to enclose comments if you would
like people to stop polluting a river
we'd give property rights to people who
are by the river to stop polluters from
doing that or keep forests from being
chopped down we get property rights to
the foresters and that kind of thing but
so analogically speaking is that
possible to do that if you will in a
medical or health Commons which is what
we're the world of bacteria and viruses
we all live in and the answer is it's
pretty hard to figure out how to do that
in a certain sense vaccination is that
kind of way making people responsible if
you will so they're not slinging their
bacteria or their my
probes at you but but what what to do in
advance to if you will protect the
Commons from invasion from outside I
think what we it's mostly going to come
down to smart technological solutions is
going to be basically figuring out
surveillance which we're going to get
better and better at I mean it was kind
of astonishing that again trusting the
Chinese they found out about the virus
and within a month they had sequenced it
and given it to the entire world
and you know if we were back in the
1950s we still wouldn't know what is hit
hit us yet so we've already made
tremendous progress in that regard and
we're gonna make a lot more I think in
the future so surveillance is key to
that then we have to clear clear up the
regulations so that people can start
deploying things like the testing the
Diagnostics much faster than we were
able to do in the United States and then
furthermore we you know eventually I
think that it will be possible to use
computational strategies to figure out
vaccines much more quickly than we do
now and get them to market but that's
you know a year no in ten years maybe
you know do you is this something that
you think we'll learn from as a society
or as a government and use this to stop
something that is truly catastrophic I
mean I'm kind of presuming this is not
going to kill you know half of us or
anything like that
but that you know for a the next big
pandemic because you know were there
lessons I mean it seems like there were
lessons we should have learned from past
experiences that we didn't bring us to
here you know are we going to learn you
know are we are we going to learn from
this or are we going to be caught either
fighting this thing again and again into
the future or just get blindsided by
something you know whatever comes next
it would be very hard for me to imagine
and I hope this is not just optimism is
that by having a multitrillion-dollar
hit to our economy we won't decide that
we're going to start have to take that
we're going to have to start taking more
precautionary measures in the future for
preventing exactly this kind of thing
happening again I just can't imagine
that we won't be able to figure out how
to do that there'll be a lot of time and
attention devoted to it and if it's not
then well you know yeah is this a
paradigm shift in terms of you know
recognizing the interconnection of you
know infection and of individuals in the
way that we transmit it that you know
that when you're talking about you know
the the basic mechanism here is a lot of
testing and then quarantine of infected
individuals until they're no longer a
threat you know that is going to be the
way that we do every aspect of our lives
where we are quicker to submit to that
kind of protocol and to squeeze things
out so that we actually have you know in
a weird way that we trade proactively a
little bit of individual freedom or opt
out in order to have a world where we're
not going to be locked down every time
there is some kind of scary disease out
there no I think that's exactly right
but again if we have a robust
surveillance system for example and a
tracking and tracing system that guards
privacy which can be done you would be
we would have been able to to if you
will lock down a thousand people for 14
weeks for 14 days and the epidemic
wouldn't have existed I mean that's
ideal but that could have been a
paradigm that we can have in the future
if we would be willing to do that I
think that I you know I personally would
not want to infect my neighbor with my
microbes if if I you know if I can be
told all right this is this is what you
need to do to protect your neighbors
right and this is also one of the
distinctions I think you know early on
that was worth drawing is that if you I
mean I assume if you're in a country
like China an authoritarian regime and
you you know that people are getting
sick and you know that the government
like if you report to the government
that you're sick you're you're done like
you you you're never heard from again
well
something like that in an open society
where you can have some trust and
confidence in the authorities and in
rule of law you would be more than
willing to quarantine yourself a report
in order to spare things but you know
are we coming out of this where you and
I have talked about this in other
contexts I've written a lot about it as
well over the past 50 years
you know the rates of trust and
confidence in all institutions in
America both public and private have
just you know gone from up here you know
through the floor you know is the way
that the country or the you know the
official apparatus is responding is that
going to build that kind of trust where
people are more likely to offer up
information or to be kind of like in a
prisoner's dilemma where they're like
[ __ ] it looking out for myself because I
really don't trust the other people I
fear that it's going to be the case that
this the way that has been handled the
this pandemic has been handled I don't
think it's going to be building trust I
think that it has been handled abysmally
I hope that what comes out of this is
that there will be groups who are who
are incentivized both political groups
but civil society groups who are
incentivized to try to figure out how to
build such trust in the future it's it's
I I'm I'm kind of horrified to see how
badly it was handled the United States
and by the fact that was handled so
badly I'm afraid will will actually
erode trust further okay
well on that happy note we're gonna
leave this conversation Ron Bailey
reasons longtime science correspondent
author most recently the end of doom of
all books Ron Bailey thanks for talking
the letter to be with you and stay well
this has been the recent interview with
Nicholas P thanks for listening please
subscribe to this podcast and other
recent podcast at reason.com slash
podcasts
you
[Music]